it's taco tuesday and we are thrilled to
celebrate with our friends from pj's
tacos and joining me now is the owner
javier
javier show me some of your breakdowns
oh so i did the whole oh hit my hand hit
my hand hit it
whoa okay
okay all right all right let's do it we
have some tequila before this so that's
why we're little
you are the taco tuesday headquarters
but not just tuesdays mondays wednesdays
every day there's no wrong day to have a
taco and you guys are in the ground in
the gramercy pinches tacos and you know
being mexican it's we're lucky we have
a holiday every week which is taco
tuesday so we can wednesday and thursday
and friday and all that good stuff right
now and you guys have excellent
margaritas and you're gonna make us some
drinks today i'm going to make you our
house margarita the blood orange
one of our pet peeves that people do not
make the margarita strong enough okay so
here i think
well you know what it's supposed to be
smooth but slap you at the same time if
that makes any sense right
so we always do a two ounce pour okay
uno los tres quatto
there we go so two ounce pours count to
four four but do it fast okay so people
do one two you do a fast one two three
four and you're set this is our secret
we're not giving it out you guys this is
our blood orange mix okay that you could
buy
add pinches tacos you do eight ounces of
this
oh so good oh man this looks amazing
already you know you do a little shot
and then i slapped the hand then you
slapped the hand again
and then i poured i did see we're a good
team girl i love this i need a job what
are you doing on tuesdays
so we just poured like actually i don't
have a strainer but i'm doing the whole
thing okay here we go voila and like i
said we sell i think about 100 of these
a day so we just keep people happy
do i get to try it oh my goodness these
are world famous i'm telling you i
and you guys are in the gramercy 215 and
russell you've got to stop by and this
month
we're raising money for opportunity
village every blood orange margarita you
buy we give one dollar to opportunity
village so please come by for a good
cause oh my gosh that is amazing
did you feel that slap i just got
slapped wow tell us about your tacos
here we have so at pinchas tacos we keep
it simple handmade corn tortilla we have
your chicken taco we also have a gringo
taco please no one get insulted that's
our hard shell shredded beef mozzarella
we deep fry it we had homemade chipotle
cream sauce lettuce and tomato and my
favorite the al pastor oh and again
there's nothing like a taco without
without a fresh uh made tortilla it just
adds that little you know that jono
sequoia that's not mexican that's french
slime
just you're gonna say quoi
you you guys have other types of fair
too i mean what we do from enchiladas to
burritos we also serve breakfast we have
the best chilaquiles in town yes bryce
from bw we do have the best cheetah he's
my neighbor we always get in it together
he's been on the show before yeah he has
yeah yeah bryce we love pj's tacos this
is the best margarita i've ever had i
can definitely say that you guys are
fantastic thank you so much thank you so
much cheers
just the whole bottle i'm old school
right you're gonna make one too
i love it you can enjoy pizza tacos
today or any day of the week at the
gramercy office 215 and russell jillian
cheers i'm going to send it over to